is it possible to experience the
stratosphere is it possible to build a
system to go into the stratosphere we
proceeded to do just that
I can guarantee that in the next
generation of space telescopes we will
have the capability to find and identify
other Earth's
what Mayton blazed are so special is
that they're some of the universe's most
efficient particle accelerators
transporting incredible amounts of
energy throughout a galaxy now we were
inspired by the Terminator 2 scene
41,000 and we fought why couldn't a 3d
printer operate in this fashion arise
out of a puddle in essentially real time
to make a great object
it's called CRISPR cast line the CRISPR
technology allows scientists to make
changes to the DNA in cells that could
allow us to cure genetic disease so what
we found is that an old mouse that gets
young blood through the shared
circulation looks younger and functions
younger in its brain
we looked for the possibility of
creating life-sustaining clothing for
interplanetary voyages this wearable
digestive system when it stretched
end to end it spans 60 meters and here
it is for the first time unveiled at Ted
our first photosynthetic wearable liquid
channels glowing with life inside a
wearable clothing what if our technology
could sense our emotions what if my
devices could sense how we felt and
reacted accordingly just the way an
emotionally intelligent friend would we
just start to scratch the surface of the
true power of virtual reality
it connects humans to other humans in a
profound way that I've never seen before
and any other form of media as I'm
speaking my sound is getting captured by
the tablet and then it's getting mapped
onto a vest that's covered in vibratory
motors and I'm wearing the vest right
now so as I'm speaking I'm feeling the
sonic world around me we've been testing
this with deaf people now and it turns
out that after just a little bit of time
people can start feeling they can start
understanding the language of the vest
we do 3 million miles of testing in our
simulators every single day so you can
imagine the experience our vehicles have
we are looking forward to having this
technology on the road how soon can we
bring it out these are my two boys my
oldest son is 11 and that means in four
and a half years he's going to be able
to get his driver's license my team and
I are committed to making sure that
doesn't happen
okay so relax don't hit it
right now your brain is controlling your
arm and it's also controlling his arm so
go ahead and just do it one more time
it says perfect machine intelligence is
the last invention that humanity will
ever need to make the machines would
them be better at the bending than we
are we should not be confident in our
ability to keep a superintelligence
genie locked up in its bottle forever
the answer here is to figure out how to
create super intelligent AI such that
even if when it escaped it is still safe
because it is fundamentally on our side
because it shares our values the Islamic
state beheadings are not ancient or
remote they're entirely dependent on the
power of technology to connect us there
is a very personal price to public
humiliation and the growth of the
Internet has jacked up that price
when we say that black lives matter it's
not because others don't it's simply
because we must affirm that we are
worthy of existing without fear when so
many things tell us we are not I want to
live in a world where my son will not be
presumed guilty the moment he is born
where a toy in his hand isn't mistaken
for anything other than a toy can we
imagine in a criminal justice system
that prioritizes recovery prevention
Civic inclusion rather than punishment a
criminal justice system that believes in
black young people rather than treating
black young people as the enemy to be
rounded up if you are fleeing a war zone
a better life is alive in safety its
life in dignity a better life means not
having a house bombs not fearing being
kidnapped it means being able to send a
children to school or just find work to
be able to provide for yourself and the
ones you love there are still tragedies
that happen in the bumpy road to
equality but there are also stories of
hope and courage in every corner of the
world
unconscious bias is not the same as
conscious discrimination I'm not saying
that in all of you there's a secret
sexist or racist or urges like lurking
within waiting to get out bias is not an
accusation rather it's something that
has to be identified acknowledged and
mitigated against we have to start
making stopping violence indispensable
to the fight against poverty in fact any
conversation about global poverty that
doesn't include the problem of violence
must be deemed not serious the quarter
truths and limited plot lines have us
convinced that poor people are a problem
that needs fixing what if we realized
that the experts we are looking for the
experts we need to follow are poor
people themselves these big issues that
will change the world change national
security change economics create hope
create threats can only be resolved when
you bring together groups of people who
understand science and technology back
together with government we won't solve
our problems if we expect it to be
solved by a few Superman or super women
now we need everybody everybody
underestimates how often they laugh when
you laugh with people that's actually
letting you access a really ancient
evolutionary system to regulate emotions
to make ourselves feel better some
affairs add bethe nails for
relationships that were already dying on
the vine but others will jolt us into
new possibilities the opposite of
addiction is not sobriety the opposite
of addiction is connection
for most people the scariest thing about
death isn't being dead it's dying I am
asking we make space physical psychic
room to allow life to play itself all
the way out so that rather than just
getting out of the way aging and dying
can become a process of crescendo
through to the end
I've learned about the poetry and the
wisdom and the grace that can be found
in the words of people all around us
when we simply take the time to listen
you might have noticed that I don't have
much inflection in my voice that's why
people often confuse me with the GPS I
am a bad feminist I am a good woman I am
trying to become better and how I think
and what I say and what I do without
abandoning everything that makes me
human the tool was bought four days in
your life the day you're born and they
do discover why and sound is so powerful
that it could either disempower me and
my artwork or it could empower me I
chose to be empowered
maybe these conversations will remind us
what's really important and maybe just
maybe it will help us recognize that
simple truth that every life every
single life matters equally and
infinitely